All right, next up, this is a very important story.
Drew, I know you hate traffic.
Yeah!
It's so funny 'cause there's nothing you really hate
in the world except for listen,
when I say this word traffic.
(Drew screams)
Okay, well, I actually hate traffic too.
Anyone else?
It's just like it turns a nice person into an angry person.
Well, listen to this, "UPI" reports,
"A man in Washington State."
Shout out to my home state Washington,
"Was pulled over for using the HOV lane
"with a skeleton in a hoodie riding in the passenger seat."
That's an actual picture.
And not a bad job, buddy, I have to say.
Got away with it,
but I think finally did get pulled over.
Every time I'm in a mall and I see those mannequins,
I'm like, "Mmh."
Do you know what's funny?
First of all, this person, I know it's wrong.
I totally get it.
Love your rebellion, and your craftiness,
and your illegal ways.
However, I don't like the HOV lane.
(Ross speaking in foreign language)
I don't, it's not one I opt for.
I like to zig and zag.
Don't trap me.
You're trapping me in the lane.
Oh, I love it.
(Drew screams)
Oh, I love it, Drew.
No!
Oh, I ride in the HOV lane and I just look at the people
who are stuck, like (chuckles).
(audience laugh)
But have you ever been stuck in the HOV lane
and you see everyone sailing past you?
Yes, I have Drew, but I don't wanna talk about it.
Well, I'm not an HOV laner, but I'm super into this story
and it's naughty, and I can appreciate it.
(upbeat music)